that's what we have if you can't see
that if you want if you're that blunt
how did Joe Biden become so rich being a
public servant for all of these years
why did Hunter Biden have a job for 80
grand a month working at a Ukrainian
energy when he was a crack smoking porn
addict like any of these things and
there's a whole bunch more we have
emails talking about the 10 and
everything else okay uh but the media is
going to go out of its way to hide this
thing uh this is uh Congressman Scott
Perry from Pennsylvania a republican
explaining exactly why the Republicans
are doing what they're doing yes ma'am
evidence do you have as a
as obligation
sorry of Joe Biden and prove that today
isn't just about some of you oh I don't
know
McCarthy for the sake of enacting
political Revenge this isn't about
political Revenge we have the bank
accounts we can see ma'am you can see
that the homes that dividends own can't
be afforded on a congressional or Senate
salary you also understand that it's not
normal for family members to receive
millions of dollars from overseas
interest those things aren't normal
that's not normal to have 20 cell shell
Country Companies these things are not
normal and it alludes to not only just
widespread corruption but money
laundering if not influence peddling
itself and we also have the president
the vice president at the time on record
saying that the prosecutor was fine well
son of a the prosecutor was fired
right because the prosecutor was going
after the the company that his son was
working on that's what we have if you
can't see that if you want if you are
that blind but I'll turn it over the
attorneys people can't see that they
think it's political it's because you
don't report on it yeah I don't know who
that report order was but like oh the
people don't see that yeah he's right
you guys don't report on it it's a isn't
doesn't it feel like the whole thing is
like bursting forth right now and I
don't know how the machine always stays
one step ahead but it will have this
thing too but it's like there are the
wire transfers the Ukrainian prosecutor
who got fired right who has uh Perry
just pointed out he was looking in to
the Biden family uh we have uh Phoenix
has given me some information on the Fly
here uh he's giving me below is a
summary of the Third Bank records
memorandum the full memorandum can be
found here committee staff is releasing
payments from Russia Kazakhstan and
Ukraine that occurred during Joe Biden's
vice presidency the committee now has
identified over 20 million in payments
from foreign sources to the Biden family
and their business associate sorry if I
butchered that a little bit but okay so
they have over 20 million dollars in
wiring funds to the Biden family over
the years that he was vice president
why his son was a crack addict working
at an energy company did it have
anything to do with the fact that his
dad was the vice president so there's
money laundering there's undue influence
there's a whole bunch of stuff here but
you know if you're a reporter oh it just
seems like retribution you Republicans
are pouncing on everything
thank you